How many refugees has Poland taken?
Zero. And you're proud of that?
If you are asking me if you are.
If you are asking me about Muslim.
Uh, Muslims. Illegal immigration. None.
Not even one will come to Poland.
Not even one.
If it's illegal.
We. We took over 2 million Ukrainians who are working,
who are peaceful in Poland.
We will not receive even one Muslim,
because this is what we promised.
But I ask about this illegal immigrants.
I asked about refugees.
And Junkord,
you younger,
the commission president,
says that you're racist.
You sound proud
of the fact that you haven't taken any refugees.
Of course, because this is what our people
expecting from our government.
That's number one.
This is why our government was elected.
That. This is why Poland is so safe.
This is the.
The reason why we have not even one terrorist attack.
Look at the streets in Poland.
And we can be called populists,
nationalists,
racists. I don't care.
I care about my family and about my country.